votre problème est que vous pensez que
la meilleure préparation à un ménage à
un couple réussit et d'avoir si vous
voulez des expériences sexuelles avant
le mariage tout à fait je trouve ça
absolument aberrant qu'on se marie sans
se connaître
les Français connaîtraient donc mal les
problèmes de leur sexualité parce que
d'abord ce sont des choses qu'on
enseigne pas qu'on n'apprend pas aux
gens ce qu'on peut dire par exemple que
le nombre des avortements qui est très
grand je crois en France est-ce que vous
avez une idée de ce chiffre et bien il
est absolument impossible de faire une
statistique exacte des avortements étant
donné que nous médecins nous ne voyons
que les avortements compliqués dans les
maisons de santé ou dans les hôpitaux
mais des hommes comme le professeur
pied-de-lièvre ont prouvé qu'il y avait
à peu près autant d'avortement que de
naissance en France si même ce chiffre
est exagéré nous pouvons considérer
qu'il existe en France à peu près 300
000 avortement par an qui serait dû pour
beaucoup certainement au manque
d'éducation sexuelle vous pensez que les
peuple français vous pensez que c'est
une conséquence directe je pense que ce
n'est pas la seule conséquence directe
mais je pense que c'est une des
conséquences importantes nous avons
rencontré d'abord une jeune femme qui
nous raconte son expérience de jeune
fille lorsqu'elle a été enceinte au
sortir d'un collège religieux lorsque
vous êtes trouvé enceinte
est-ce que vous étiez préparé est-ce que
vous vous doutiez que ce genre
d'inconvénients pouvait arriver
j'y pensais pas en fait
il y avait beaucoup d'inconscience je
crois
j'étais jeune et on ne m'avait jamais
prévenu enfin jamais parlé de ces choses
là évidemment je savais très bien que
comment se faisait les enfants ça
sûrement je le savais je n'y pensais pas
toujours l'impression ces gens de choses
qui arrivent aux autres et pas à soi et
moi-même quand je me suis trouvée
enceinte
je pense absolument pas que c'était ça
je pensais que il fallait que j'aille
voir un médecin et puis j'ai cru j'avais
mal au cœur j'ai cruauté des crises de
foi au début j'ai soigné mon foie tout
absolument pas que j'étais enceinte
je suis pas du tout je me suis pas du
tout affolé
quelle avait été votre éducation avant
en éducation dans ce domaine là avait
été je peux dire pratiquement nulle
je considère maintenant que tout ce que
j'ai je sais enfin tout ce que j'ai
appris je l'ai appris par moi-même à
partir de ce moment-là enfin à partir de
19 ans là je me suis trouvé libre à
moi-même dans Paris seul et je l'ai
appris tout par moi-même et à mes
dépenses je veux dire j'ai toujours été
dans les pensions religieuses
et religieuse n'abordait jamais jamais
ces sujets là absolument pas et alors
quand à ma mère
non plus c'était le grand silence vous
avez l'impression que c'est les
directrices de ces maisons qui vous le
reçoivent qui vous accueillent en
principe condamne en même temps le fait
que vous soyez célibataire et enceinte
toute ma grosse sage je n'ai entendu que
certaines maisons étaient
religieuses alors on faisait dire enfin
dans certaines maisons il a fallu dire
des chapelets le soir à genoux en
réparation pour demander pardon
enfin c'était toujours le côté
de la faute qui qui apparaissait les
jeunes filles n'en savent à peu près
autant que les femmes mariées souvent
car l'absence d'éducation sexuelle se
retrouve à tous les niveaux et bien
souvent des femmes mariées maire du
nombreuses familles n'ont aucune idée de
ce qu'elle pourrait faire pour dominer
ce problème et pour éviter les
maternités il n'y a pas que les
problèmes des jeunes filles quand les
jeunes vivent de plus en plus ensemble
ils parlent de ces problèmes et ils
essayent de les résoudre c'est souvent
bien sûr parce que l'ami a eu quelques
ennuis qu'on voit arriver à une
consultation de contraception les trois
ou quatre meilleurs amis de la jeune
femme qui a été enceinte par exemple
c'est encore trop tard ce que nous
aimerions voir c'est des jeunes filles
décidées à prendre en charge la
responsabilité de leur vie qui viennent
avant toute expérience malheureuse
ensuite il y a l'avortement
commencez sa vie sexuelle par un
avortement c'est certainement
l'expérience et physique et psychique la
plus affreuse et c'est pourquoi pour
nous gynécologue c'est un c'est triste
de voir que neuf fois sur 10 quand on
apprend une maternité à une jeune femme
c'est le pire des Paypal le pire des
drames
vous pariez tout à l'heure des hommes
qui effectivement je crois ne se sentent
pas concerné il ne se sentent pas
concernée non seulement vis-à-vis des
jeunes filles mais même lorsqu'ils sont
mariés bien souvent dans les
consultations de contraception que vous
pouvez avoir ce que vous avez des hommes
qui viennent et quel est leur attitude
les hommes viennent souvent mais enfin
dans l'ensemble il faut dire qu'ils sont
heureux de pouvoir se décharger de cette
responsabilité qu'en général ils sont
ravis de ne pas dans l'entendre parler
d'avoir rien à faire c'est une jeune
fille que nous avons présenté oui à une
gynécologue catholique qui est ouverte
au problème de l'information sexuelle
alors quel est votre vrai problème à
vous exposez moi votre cas mais voilà
que pensez-vous d'une mineure qui est
fiancée bon officiellement enfin je suis
assez plus ou moins avec un garçon
qu'elle peut pas épouser pour l'instant
le problème se pose parce que il y a
aucune raison que sous on a 18 ans et
pas 21 ans on n'est pas le droit d'être
heureux absolument mais alors est-ce que
l'obstacle quel est l'obstacle à sparia
c'est un obstacle absolu non absolu il
ne temporaire en somme votre problème et
que vous pensez que la meilleure
préparation à un ménage à un couple
réussit et d'avoir si vous voulez des
expériences sexuelles avant le mariage
tout à fait je trouve ça absolument
aberrant qu'on se marie ça sans se
connaître et se connaître se connaître
aussi bien moralement que physiquement
alors là je crois peut-être que vous
n'êtes pas dans la vérité vous croyez
pas non je le crois pas et je ne crois
pas que ce soit une bonne préparation à
une vie conjugale heureuse et épanouie
que de mettre la charrue avant les bœufs
je crois que la connaissance physique et
le parachèvement du reste de la
connaissance parce qu'un jeune ménage
qui manifestement un ménage d'étudiants
qui manifestement ne peut pas envisager
un enfant parce qu'il est même pas dans
les conditions requises pour
l'accueillir et bien à ce moment-là le
planning familial joue à fond
permet à ce jeune couple moi j'en vois
tous les jours dans ce cas-là permet à
ce jeune couple de prendre Allen de
faire son unité voyez-vous c'est unité
du couple qui est cette chose
merveilleuse erreur voyez-vous deux
jeunes qui considèrent que pendant les
fiançailles il faut avoir une union
totale je crois c'est comme des enfants
qui aiment la tarte aux cerises veulent
la manger avant qu'elle aille au four
je prends pas que ce soit mal de coucher
avec son fiancé quand on l'aime je crois
que c'est dommage voyez-vous je crois
que c'est dommage parce qu'on gage
quelque chose le besoin physiologique il
existe malgré tout oui le besoin surtout
pour le garçon alors là je crois encore
que sur lesquels vous comprenez ça il
n'existe pas plus pour le garçon que
pour la fille bien entendu il existe ça
ne fait pas de doute mais il existe
certainement moins intensément quand il
n'a pas déjà été réalisé d'autre part il
existe vous avouez bien qu'on fait bien
un tout pour qu'il soit multiplié et
démultiplier vous ne pouvez pas échanger
sans Élysée sans avoir des ça a l'air
des cuissons au vent c'est pas c'est
natifs vous voyez volupté sous les
tropiques c'est vrai vous voyez l'amour
par si la pension par là la société
certainement mal conditionnée dans ce
domaine là croyez-vous qu'une jeune
fille si mémé adore son fiancé va
coucher avec lui dans une chambre
d'hôtel croyez-vous vraiment que c'est
le rêve pour une jeune fille encore une
fois on peut on doit pouvoir le
surmonter c'est oui mais pourquoi tu
remonté pourquoi
ne nous permet pas d'être autrement
mais dire à ça que ça vous donne le
bonheur non disons que j'ai pu connaître
des instants de bonheur et c'est déjà
beaucoup parce que tout le monde
français pour le planning familial c'est
à dire que vous êtes le la téléspectrice
idéale pour ce que nous venons
d'entendre est-ce qu'il y a quelque
chose qui vous choque dans ce dialogue
oui je crois que le médecin ne peut pas
être moralisateur vis-à-vis des femmes
et des jeunes filles qui viennent lui
demander conseil
doctoresse soit moralisatrice est-ce que
ça vient de ces certitudes de
religieuses
mais personnellement je suis catholique
comme elle puisque en a présenté comme
un médecin catholique et je pense que en
aucun cas nous devons avoir une attitude
moralisatrice vous avez une opérations
elle reçoivent très de façon très
ouverte tout ce qu'on leur demande et
elle pose des questions excessivement
nombreuses et fortes intéressantes
prouvant premièrement qu'elles n'ont pas
reçu une éducation sexuelle
préalablement et qu'elles en ont
vraiment besoin et qu'elles ont des
fausses notions qui se chargent de cet
enseignement cet enseignement est
dispensé par les professeurs de sciences
naturelles
jusqu'à présent il était dispensé de
façon absolument certaine en classe
terminale il semble que les nouveaux
programmes nous autorisent bien que ça
ne soit pas spécifiquement indiqué nous
autorise à continuer cette enseignement
à le faire dès la classe de Première
l'exemple qui est pris par les
programmes c'est Laura c'est Laura donc
les élèves ils ont fait part de
difficultés de transposition oui
certaines ont fait une transposition
enfin les élèves qui ont déjà quelques
connaissances on fait une transposition
facile et
ces élèves ont parlé entre elles en
dehors du cours et certaines sont venus
me dire que pour d'autres cet exemple
avait plutôt jeté un trouble la
transposition étant difficile
et ont demandé des demander qu'on traite
effectivement le cycle variole sur le
terrain de la femme ce qui intéresse les
élèves c'est l'anatomie l'anatomie a été
supprimée du programme des grandes
parties des classes terminales on estime
actuellement leur fin programme de
physiologie en estimant qu'ils
connaissent l'anatomie depuis la classe
de 3e ils ont oublié en trois ans
l'anatomie et chaque fois que l'on fait
un rappel d'anatomie sont très
intéressés alors ce qui les intéresse
surtout c'est l'anatomie des organes
génitaux ils s'oppose donc le problème
très grave de savoir si on va décider
avec netteté que pour tous les petits
français il devra y avoir une formation
et une information sexuelle ce qui
voudrait dire que pour cela il n'y
aurait pas un vaste programme biologique
mais il y aurait juste ce qu'il faut
savoir et connaître relativement à
l'éducation sexuelle j'ai accepté faire
cet entretien devant la caméra sur les
questions sexuelles avec Guillaume mon
dernier petit garçon qui a 8 ans parce
que personne ne voulait le faire et
parce que j'ai pensé que ce serait
intéressant tout même que qu'il soit
fait qu'est-ce que c'est que les règles
qu'est-ce que c'est que les règles
et bien c'est quelque chose qui arrive
aux dames et aux jeunes filles tous les
mois c'est-à-dire que tu sais que les
petites filles deviennent des jeunes
filles quand elles sont 13 14 ans leur
poitrine poussent et puis elle se
développe elles deviennent plus grandes
plus féminine plus belle et alors à ce
moment là vers 12-13 ans à peu près il
est tous les mois ils ont un petit
écoulement de sang qui se produit et
c'est très utile parce que tu sais pas
ce que le résultat de quoi c'est les
règles et bien tous les mois dans le
ventre des jeunes filles et des femmes
ils se forment comme un petit œuf
pas un œuf qui a une coquille dure comme
l’œuf d'une poule mais un tout petit œuf
gros comme ça et ce petit œuf il
s'écoule à l'extérieur du ventre de la
jeune fille ou de la femme tous les mois
et c'est ça qui produit le sang des
règles tous les mois et quand elles ont
leurs règles tous les mois et que ce
petit œuf sort à l'extérieur sous forme
de cet écoulement de ça et bien c'est
qu'elle n'attendent pas un enfant elle
les a une fois par mois pendant 3 ou 4
jours si elle a le bébé au milieu du
mois et ben elle le sait que 15 jours
après
si elle est enceinte à un moment du mois
et bien elle peut pas le savoir tout de
suite elle peut penser qu'elle est
enceinte parce qu'il suffit pas de pas
avoir ses règles pour être enceinte
c'est un moyen de s'en apercevoir mais
il faut aussi avoir eu des rapports avec
un homme parce que une femme ne fait pas
un enfant toute seule il faut deux
personnes pour faire un enfant il faut
un homme et une femme
alors la femme tu sais que l'enfance se
développe dans son ventre mais ce qu'il
faut toujours être marié pour avoir un
enfant
ça c'est une question intéressante mais
écoute si tu réfléchis tu verras que non
tu croyais que tu croyais que non
tu croyais que réfléchis une seconde
quand tu penses par exemple tu crois que
les chiens vont passe devant le maire et
le curé je crois que les chats passent
devant le mur et le curé mais ils ont
des enfants ils ont des petits chats et
des petits chiens alors ça prouve que
dans la nature c'est pas du tout
nécessaire de se marier pour avoir des
enfants il faut que je t'explique depuis
le début parce que ça je crois que tu
comprendrais pas très bien et bien les
dames tu sais comment elles sont faites
tu sais pas très bien elles ont un
premier petit trou qui leur sert à faire
pipi et qui correspond avec leur vessie
qui est une poche à l'intérieur de leur
ventre le plus en avant elles ont ce
tout petit Torifice là puis un petit peu
après entre leurs jambes elles ont un
autre orifice un tout petit peu plus
grand qui correspond à une poche à
l'intérieur de leur ventre comme un sac
qui sera un peu entrouvert vers en bas
mais c'est par cette ouverture d'en bas
que le père met une petite graine tu
comprends
dans l'accouchement dans l'accouchement
l'accouchement c'est le moment où le
bébé sort alors à ce moment-là l'homme
il sert à être à côté de sa femme et
assister à la naissance de son bébé mais
c'est dans la pour le faire le bébé tu
veux dire pour le faire tu sais où il
l'a fabrique et tu sais comment il la
met
et bien tu sais que très bien comment
les garçons sont faits alors tu sais
très bien que
sous tu as des testicules c'est à dire
des petites bourses où il y a des
petites graines là dedans et par le même
orifice où tu fais pipi et qui
correspond avec la vessie et bien quand
on devient un jeune homme qu'on grandit
et qu'on arrive à l'âge de la puberté
vers 14-15 ans et bien il peut sortir
d'un certain cas un autre liquide qui
n'est pas du pipi
par ce même orifice et ce liquide est
fabriqué dans les petites bourses que tu
as en dessous ce que tu appelles ton
zizi tu vois
alors le monsieur dans certains cas et
bien il vient près de la dame il l'aime
beaucoup
il embrasse la dame il l'aime beaucoup
il est content il s'aime tous les deux
c'est ça qui est le plus important ils
ont envie de se faire un grand câlin tu
vois à peu près ce que ça peut donner il
s'aime il s'embrasse alors dans certains
cas le zizi comme tu dis devient tout
dur et à ce moment-là le monsieur peut
l'introduire dans le ventre de la dame
qu'est-ce que tu en penses
tu savais ça
madame messieurs vous êtes tous les
trois médecins tous les trois engagés si
je puis dire dans ce combat pour
j'allais dire une meilleure éducation
sexuelle même une aiguille sécrétion
sexuelle tout court c'est à dire que on
la pratique or ce dernier document je
vous entendais en parler ensemble
pendant que on le diffusait ce dernier
document apparemment d'une certaine
manière même vous vous a un peu choqué
je ne suis ni d'accord ni contre mais ce
qui me frappe voyez-vous en comparant
les deux séquences que nous venons de
voir c'est l'attitude le temps ce petit
garçon il a 9 ans il n'a rien compris à
ce qu'on lui a dit bien entendu et
certainement dans 6 mois si on
l'interrogeait on serait étonné de
savoir qu'il a tout oublié ça n'a pas
d'importantes ce qui compte c'est
l'atmosphère c'est la chaleur c'est
cette mer qu'on sent attentive très
chaleureuse attentive au moindre gestes
au moindre faux pas de son enfant
attentive à le sécuriser sur ses
problèmes s'il la voit inquiète il faut
que l'enfant supporte le moins bien
c'est la contradiction il ne faut pas
qu'il apprenne quelque chose à l'école
et le contraire chez lui
et là c'est ça un problème très très
difficile et il faut certainement
commencer par éduquer les éducateurs
c'est à dire les éducateurs et les
parents il y a un certain nombre de
choses sur lesquelles me semble-t-il les
autorités officielles gouvernementales
éducation nationale les associations de
parents d'élèves et les éducateurs
devraient trouver une un terrain
d'entente c'est celui de l'information
sexuelle il est absolument injuste que
l'enfant soit averti de toutes les
fonctions digestives pulmonaires
respiratoires et il reçoivent jamais
aucune information sur la reproduction
de l'être humain ce qui est tout même ce
qu'il concerne au plus haut point et je
pense que là il y a une faiblesse de
notre enseignement et que il est
souhaitable que rapidement l'éducation
nationale prenne des mesures cela ne
résoudra pas les problèmes les problèmes
sont peut-être plus difficiles au niveau
de la petite enfance parce que là c'est
les parents qu'il faudrait non pas non
seulement informer mais quelquefois
réformer les notions préalablement
acquises je voudrais vous poser une
toute dernière question
je voudrais savoir si vous avez
vous-même résolu avec vos propres
enfants ses problèmes
je sais ton soi-même
j'ai deux enfants ils me font croire que
nous l'avons résolu ma femme et moi mais
[Musique]